we to become better at tracking student
learning gross not at just seeing where
students are at any point in time but
also seeing how they actually progress
in the learning pathways and actually a
lot is happening in that field in fact
there the Pisa assessment as we have it
currently focusing on fifteen-year-old
is looking into expanding to lower
grades so that we can actually get at
least at the synthetic level some sense
of the progress that is being made in
education raising quality improving
equity and also value for money
the Pisa data show that parents have a
very significant influence on the
success of their children we see that
their parents have a greater
expectations on education where parents
are more closely involved in the
education of their children results are
significantly better and it's not only
in terms of the academic performance of
students but it's also in terms of the
attitudes to learning the enjoyment of
learning there are persistence when
things get tough in school so parent
role involvement is very important we
also see that that parental involvement
isn't about having an academic degree as
a parent or spending hours of time on
homework it's really the interest
parents show for the education of their
children for example when parents
regularly ask they're chilled and you
know how was school today yeah what did
go wrong and we can see those kids
actually having a significantly higher
performance at school than 10 kids even
kids from wealthier neighborhoods where
parents do not show that level of
engagement so a very important
ingredient for success is to make
parents part of the equation
sure if you do well you might think you
don't need to improve but in fact the
Pisa data do not lend much evidence to
this in fact some of the most rapidly
improving systems some of the best
performing systems they want to move
from good to great they're actually
seeing you know what is the houses labor
demand shaping up in the future what are
the kind of knowledge and skills that we
need to improve on I give you an example
you can look at Singapore Singapore is
always done well on maths and science
tests but Singaporean educators have not
been satisfied Lass's they're looking to
how did how can we strengthen students
ways of thinking creativity critical
thinking problem-solving students ways
of working collaboration teamwork and so
on so the education system is actually
looking towards moving forward
complacency is a risk but we do actually
see very encouraging signals that
improvement is taking place and every
part of the system you cannot improve
what you can't measure so the
measurement framework is really really
critically important but we also do see
incentives not only for low performers
to catch up but also for the strong
performers to move forward further
a humanistic perspective is very
important to evaluating educational
results in fact we need to get away from
looking at education with a single
perspectives evaluation can only take
part plagues in a framework of multiple
kind of perspectives looking at test
data from students as one perspective
looking at teachers views on student
performance looking at other students
use it's this kind of multiplicity of
instruments that actually help us
improve education and that's true even
at the level of teachers you know you
can't evaluate teachers on the basis of
student learning outcomes it's one
perspective but you also need to bring
in other perspectives that value the
broader responsibilities that their
teachers have so looking at outcomes
from multiple perspectives including
this kind of quality qualitative outlook
is very very important